[Music]
Teen Titans go is a fun spin-off of the
popular universe of the Teen Titans
although many fans have mixed reviews
about the show we've still managed to
find some of the most impressive fan art
ever if you love Robin and Starfire make
sure you stick around till the end of
the video to see what they'd look like
as high school students don't forget to
like this video and subscribe to our
Channel let's check out 10 Teen Titans
go characters reimagined as high school
students Starfire
the sweet Starfire is among some of the
favorite characters on Teen Titans go
and we can definitely see why she's not
only beautiful but she also makes us
laugh sometimes even when she doesn't
know it
she's one of our personal favorites no
one knows how old she really is but
let's check out what she looked like as
a high school student deviantART user
Maia Shea gave us a very normal high
school girl look but yet you can still
tell it Starfire by her fiery hair
here's another one for you high school
times are full of romance so we thought
to add in star fires romantic interest
to this video Starfire and Robin are one
of our favorite couples ever and here
they are as high school students this
incredible illustration was designed by
the talented Bret Luffy on tumblr we've
seen these two share quite a few moments
but doesn't this just look way too
adorable we love these two but it looks
like a high school version of Starfire
is also making some regular friends this
illustration belongs to the very
talented pansy Ella on tumblr we all
know Starfire likes to meditate with
Raven and this illustration reminds us
what these two would look like as high
school students although these are their
regular outfits they do remind us of
school uniforms
Starfire definitely looks like she fit
in with the high school crowd Raven and
who can forget about the mysterious and
unbelievably sarcastic Raven her sense
of humor is incredibly hilarious and we
adore her smart remarks she sounds like
the character that would do very well in
high school here are a couple of totally
awesome high school Raven looks our
first one was created by the very
talented pansy Ella who made Raven look
like a typical high school kid that
marches to the beat of her own drum she
looks like a rebel and we bet she has
the same type of sense of humor the
serious art on tumblr also turned Raven
into a normal high school girl
Ryan Jam hole from deviantART
showed off his impressive artistic
skills and here we can see Raven reading
a book of course Raven being Raven she'd
probably prefer wearing her Teen Titans
go outfit than changing it to normal
people close but gret luskey from
deviantART showed us what she's looked
like as a typical high school girl she's
wearing a leather jacket green miniskirt
purple hair and carries a drink that
resembles a Starbucks we love her edgy
and cool look we can imagine Raven would
be just as mysterious and sarcastic as
she is on the show to be honest she'd
probably be one of the most popular kids
in school and she'd also be the smartest
Beast Boy let's move on to the mail I
can DM Teen Titans go everyone has a
soft spot for Beast Boy even though he
might sometimes become the butt of many
jokes we love his innocence and energy
and he never fails to make us laugh gret
Leske from deviantART we imagine Beast
Boy and his prom outfit doesn't look
totally dashing we'll show you who we
think he's taking to prom in just a
little bit let's take a look at some
other illustrations piccolo kun made him
look like a very typical high school
student and were totally in love with
his cool look he's even using an iPhone
and of course we can't forget about the
cute dog fishy bug from deviantART also
gave Beast Boy a very human look and one
of our favorite illustrations comes from
live for love 136 it shows a high school
beast boy asking Raven to prom these two
are opposite in their personalities but
we have seen them play off each other
and lay aside their differences a high
school version of Beast Boy would
definitely be cool and edgy and we
definitely see him kicking it with the
high school version of Raven even though
they're different the two really are
meant to be which subject do you think
would be beast boy's favorite Raven and
Beast Boy if you're a fan of Raven and
Beast Boy as a couple this one is for
you get ready because your heart is
about to melt we've seen Raven and Beast
Boy share their spats and sometimes get
in each other's faces but they have
definitely learned to put their
differences aside over time and get
along when they need it too it's true
that their personalities are opposite
but that doesn't mean that Teen Titans
go fans don't see them as a cute couple
check out this adorable photo of teenage
Raven and Beast Boy and what they look
like as high-school students
this illustration belongs to shock 777
on tumblr and it's the cutest thing
we've ever seen it seems like they're
really starting to put aside their
differences and here's Beast Boy totally
crushing on Raven and she's visibly
creeped out this illustration belongs to
chamsy from deviantART kashira from
tumblr also made this adorable image of
Beast Boy asking Raven to be his
Valentine and morel ortega took it to
the next level and shared this
ridiculously cute moment between the two
however fans are struggling to come up
with that perfect ship name for the two
should it be Bravin ray beast or just
Beast Boy or Raven what do you call
these two these images definitely make
us wish we could see the Teen Titans go
characters in high school and watch them
develop crushes and romances Blackfyre
unlike Starfire Blackfyre doesn't really
have a good reputation in the Teen
Titans go world despite flat fires
gorgeous looks it's her personality that
makes her one of the more subtle
villains on the show
she loves to mess around with her
younger sister and the rest of the squad
and she's almost always up to no good
we've seen her be imagined in a bunch of
different alternative universes but here
are a couple of images of what she'd
look like as a regular high school
student Maya shay from deviantART did a
fantastic job of putting black fire in
regular clothing and making her look
like any other human this would
definitely make us forget that she's not
one of the popular characters on the
show
in fact we're pretty sure most of the
Teen Titans go fans don't really have a
good opinion of black fire well it looks
like she still has some fans because
this fan art also shows a slightly
different side of her it was created by
SB 99 stuff and they mentioned they
wanted to portray her differently from
the black fire you know in the show it
definitely works
we're pretty sure black fire would be
one of those students that always gets
in trouble pulls pranks and skip school
we'd love to see he'll finally get along
with the rest of the squad and show a
different side to her even if it's just
for one day cyborg another interesting
character that never fails to make us
laugh is cyborg you wouldn't think that
he has a gentle personality but cyborg
is actually one of the friendliest
people on the Teen Titans go squad he's
outgoing and cool and we definitely see
him being a friendly jock that loves to
help under friend everyone who needs
fans who've reimagined what he'd
actually looked like in high school and
it seems like teenage cyborg is
definitely struggling with his strength
scotty 9 359 from
art reimagined cyborgs and the whole
crew during lunchtime at school and it
looks like cyborg is sharing a power
struggle with Starfire over the last
slice of pizza
kashira from tumblr made the entire team
take a selfie and we're totally in love
with cyborg sad face we're pretty sure
he could easily crush a phone if he ever
had to take a real-life selfie and then
there's this awesome illustration done
by gret luskey who showed that
high-school cyborg really isn't that
strong after all he's gym buddies with
Starfire but it looks like Starfire's
totally kicking butt we won't even
mention the struggling Beast Boy in the
background
cyborg definitely seems like he'd be a
good high school student not only would
he probably be the strongest jock on the
team but he also be one of the kindest
students around all characters at prom
apart from learning about new things and
subjects high school gives us tons of
new experiences such as first crushes
first dates new romances and much more
one of those is attending a prom an
event many are looking forward to the
most it's a completely magical time in a
student's life and we found some photos
that show all Teen Titans go characters
looking all fancy at their prom sook or
Gandhi on deviantART also threw in
characters from the original Teen Titans
and we're totally in love with this
picture obviously Beast Boy and Raven
are a couple but we can also see Robin
taking Starfire to prom how cute is that
every character is looking totally
adorable and we bet we know which two
would be crowns the king and queen of
prom here's a close-up of the photo
showing girls and boys individually
Beast Boy and Robin are stealing the
show but we're also completely in awe
with Ravens outfit we bet cyborg has the
best dance moves of them all do you
agree with their prom date choices or
would you rather see them pair up with
somebody else from the group we know
Teen Titans go fanbase has a lot of
opinions on who the characters should
date so make sure you let us know in the
comments all characters at school we've
already seen an episode where the Teen
Titans go characters attend high school
after robbing bribes them to go in that
episode Robin tried to divide the squad
because their personalities clashed with
the usual status quo you know the
popular kids don't usually hang out with
those that aren't popular and so on it
looks like these high school versions of
the squad aren't sticking to those rules
here's Brett Lucky's totally awesome
photo of the Teen Titans go squad
enjoying their time at school doesn't
Robin look like he's the coolest
around Becky Apple from deviantART also
showed them posing for a high school
portrait is that a Hogwarts scarf we see
on Raven
Liz sure l even included Tara as the
part of this high school squad and Kate
Allen made them look slightly younger
but their personalities are still
shining through and here's the final
illustration created by a tumblr user
called Markus Tech we can see Raven
practicing her meditation skills cyborg
is clearly on the football team
Robin is holding a Batman notebook
Starfire's hair is longer than ever and
Beast Boy is well Beast Boy the group is
showing us that you can definitely hang
out with whoever you want in high school
and don't have to just stick to the
people that look like you or belong to a
certain group Tara Tara is one of our
favorite underrated characters of Teen
Titans go although she's a villain we
love her ability to telepathically
communicate with the earth and
manipulate it in any way she wants to
that's a pretty awesome superpower if
you ask us Tara actually looks slightly
less intimidating at the high schooler
and we have photo evidence to prove it
the first image belongs to Bret luskey
who gave Tara a very innocent look you'd
hardly believe this is the same girl
that could easily manipulate the earth
and caused so much trouble in the Teen
Titans go world use 2210 also dressed
her in a schoolgirl outfit and turned
her into the cutest thing we have ever
seen doesn't she remind you of Sailor
Moon on the other hand Ramona Michelle
Yi reimagined her as a new kid in school
and a geology teacher's pet if there
would be anyone that loves geology it
would definitely be Tara
Ramona also noted that this version of
Tara also probably owns an Etsy shop
with her mother and enjoys crafts that
involves stones the artist also points
out that due to being sheltered and
naive Tara eventually falls into the
wrong crowd which could be why she
becomes the villain we know today we can
easily see a high school Tara getting
along with the mysterious Raven Robin as
the leader of the group we've seen Robin
get annoyed at others time and time
again they won't do as he says and
they'll often disobey Him just to annoy
him isn't that what friendship is all
about we've previously seen a Teen
Titans go episode where he tries to
separate the group and make them hang
out with their own crowds and obviously
this doesn't work Robin is definitely
the cool kid and this is pretty obvious
even in these amazing illustrations
Brett Leslie gave us a whole timeline of
how Robin grew up through the years and
he does look like a student in the
middle picture and we all know Robin and
Starfire
kind of a thing so we managed to find
what they'd look like studying hard for
an exam this illustration belongs to the
talented Yasui and it looks like a
student version of Robin is way too
tired to pay attention to anything but
the cutest illustration of Robin and
Starfire as students belongs to Darr
draws from tumblr who managed to
beautifully capture with these two would
look like in a school setting we can't
decide if Robin would be one of the cool
kids or if you've learned as much as you
possibly can however you cannot deny
that Robin is definitely looking like a
cool high school kid we'd love to hang
out with that's it for ten teen titans
go characters reimagined as high school
students make sure to check out ten Teen
Titans go characters in the real life we
can't wait to see you in the next video
[Music]